how's the gum resume welcome to gas man
so you might have seen this game before
I haven't actually played it I'm excited
to click ass we'll save that one for
later
for now let's let's play this game so
I'm the red one
Go Go Red Team all attack the ball no
stop the ball please for the love of God
stop it
what are you doing that was the worst
thing I've seen in my life hump the
ground yeah you better hump the ground
yeah jab it alright let's try that again
attack red team everyone attack that
taxi did not work just go to the ball
what are you doing what is yeah oh my
god giant gangbang in the metal Y Z half
of them can't even why are you so bad
walking come on ball you got it
why are that you're not frogs don't fall
don't fall don't fall shoot shoot match
time over draw you kidding me
alright alright you got this get the
ball
yes it's down now's your chance
[ __ ] em I mean now's your chance hit the
ball good job good job you can run out
to the desert for all I care goddamn it
Jared fell down Jerry got up Jerry
tackle him [ __ ]
kick the Bears kick it [ __ ] is you're a
peon stop humping each other this is not
football what a [ __ ] is the goal gamer
toy alright I'm gonna score if the last
thing I'll ever do go yes you guys move
forward go come on kick it huh kick it
again
kick it in Ian oh yeah she's down oh my
god oh yeah please get up please get up
wait yeah yeah come on what are you
doing you can add more balls what does
that do
alright now we're talking
hopefully one will go in come on come on
No another one another one come on
yeah hey [ __ ] them maybe not that many
balls yes now we are talking all right I
win yeah actually everyone wins in a
gangbang okay maybe not that many
teammates now let here we go okay I can
control him manually awesome nice going
man [ __ ]
yes now it's my chance why did you kick
it what are you doing
kick the ball he's big dancing in front
of me and he's better than me that is
when you know you should probably not
take aa cat damn this is incredibly
frustrating man what is it now
no no no don't lick my ass oh come on
son of a [ __ ] now come on don't help me
kick him kick him super kick nailed it
that's what you get Jerry frog attack
frog the attack yes frog psychic powers
made him fall I can't I can't
all right okay click ass what is this
wonderful Oh BAM Oh are they making out
what are you doing my YouTube video is
gonna get flagged get that ass get that
sweet ass that's right
for month s see if we can hit that guy's
head Jimmy Chang Chang [ __ ] I think on
bass god aah oh god they're just
standing there yeah it may be in a
million years so we'll score so um as is
even better look at this screen you
can't even score in that it go let's do
Titan oh my god if this is how sports
wear I would probably actually watch it
if that sport should be just drugs and
sexiness I guess it's not too far away
from it all right come on now's your
chance
now it's your chance get it in get it in
get it in get it in please a great ass
can only get to you so far in life oh
thank god oh my god I'm so happy oh yeah
oh yeah Sweden Sweden Sweden Sweden
Twitter where rad radford sorry but I
don't usually get to cheer for Sweden so
all right this should be hot this is
football ladies and Pres here we go it's
like the subway in London it's awesome
yeah maybe one day they will score a
goal no one knows but until then they
will have a gangbang hey hey what the ha
ha oh my god okay cool here we go go my
minions go far they don't really want to
play football today
gee I thought I was bad at sports
what is he doing oh my god you got damn
it all right you know what that will
have to do it for that but it's a fun
game and it's free so you can check it
out I'll leave a link in the description
it's the sky come bread today and like I
mean
watching thousand births love you